we do not accept the Sham referendum
and any kind of annexation in Ukraine
and we're determined to make the Kremlin
pay
for this further escalation
So today we're together proposing a new
package of biting sanctions against
Russia
in direct response to the latest Russia
escalation escalation
for example to calling 300 000 soldiers
to the war
we propose to adopt additional
restrictive measures against those
individuals who are supporting
facilitating or benefiting from the
invasion of Ukraine
so we propose sweeping new import bans
on Russian products
this will keep Russian products out of
the European market
and deprive Russia of an additional 7
billion euros in revenues
we're also proposing to extend the list
of products that cannot be exported to
Russia anymore
the aim is here to deprive the kremlin's
military complex
of key Technologies
this oil price cap will help reduce
Russia's revenues on one hand and it
will keep the global market for energy
stable on the other hand
so today in this package here we're
laying the legal basis for this oil
price cap